*-Manifestation autorisée
et maintenue
pour les anti-CADA.
Rendez-vous 9h,
place de la République
à Bélâbre.
-Bélâbre
une commune de 940 âmes
au coeur du Berry,
dans l'Indre.
Ici, les habitants
se déchirent sur l'installation
prochaine d'un centre
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile,
un CADA.
En 9 mois,
c'est la quatrième fois
qu'ils manifestent.
*-La manifestation anti-CADA
est autorisée
et maintenue...
-L'Ile-de-France concentre
près de la moitié
des demandes d'asile.
L'Etat veut
mieux les répartir et souhaite
que les régions prennent leur part.
L'Indre,
département sous-doté,
va créer 60 nouvelles places
d'accueil.
38 dans cette petite commune
rurale.
Et ça ne fait pas vraiment
l'unanimité.
-On va les mettre là,
les parquer au fond,
sans rien, sans jardin,
sans activité.
Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
Ma crainte, c'est de voir des gens
qui ne pourront rien faire
de la journée faire des bêtises
car ils s'ennuient.
-Dans des tous petits villages,
où les gens ont l'habitude de vivre
très tranquillement,
où il n'y a ni transport,
où il n'y a rien à faire,
je comprends que les gens se posent
des questions.
-Depuis que le projet a été annoncé
par le maire,
c'est tout le village
qui s'est crispé.
-Le maire a réussi
une chose formidable :
diviser en deux
sa population.
-Ca a créé deux...
Deux mondes différents, du coup.
-Ca a été mal préparé initialement,
et voilà, aujourd'hui...
C'est la guéguerre.
-Un village
coupé en deux.
Le maire ne peut plus se déplacer
dans les rues
sans être pris à partie.
-Bonjour.
Musique pesante
-J'ai dit bonjour,
il m'a dit :
"Tu oses me dire bonjour ?"
-Il a posté
sur les réseaux sociaux
que l'usine, là, pouvait...
Etre brûlée.
-L'usine, c'est cette ancienne
chemiserie désaffectée.
C'est elle que Laurent Laroche
a revendue
à l'association Viltaïs.
Elle doit être
transformée en CADA,
un centre d'accueil
pour demandeurs d'asile.
-Je viens là avec émotion,
ma maman y a travaillé.
Ici, il y avait 120 ouvrières
dans les années 50-60
jusqu'au début des années 80.
Ces ouvrières fabriquaient
des chemises
pour la haute couture française,
Pierre Cardin, Christian Dior.
On va monter à l'étage.
On arrive dans la grande pièce
qui sera aménagée pour l'étage,
vous voyez dans quel état c'est.
-On a tout à écrire.
-Il a tout à écrire.
-Karine Bouteleux, en charge
du projet pour Viltaïs,
visite pour la première fois
les locaux.
-Là, on sera dans la salle
de l'étage où il y aura
des chambres,
des douches et des toilettes.
-Et, si ma mémoire est bonne,
un coin buanderie
pour qu'ils aient
des machines à laver.
Le bas sera plus
sur les activités collectives
avec des bureaux qui seront...
Qui permettront de travailler
les dossiers de demande d'asile.
-600 mètres carrés
pour accueillir
38 demandeurs d'asile.
-Ca fait un très bel espace.
-Les combles seraient
aménageables ?
C'est la superficie
qui nous a plu,
et comme je le disais,
il y a tout à écrire.
C'est vrai que là,
on a 4 murs, un toit,
et on va pouvoir faire
ce qu'on a envie de faire.
-Mais pour l'instant,
pas de travaux en vue.
Annoncée en février,
9 mois après,
la vente n'est toujours pas
signée.
-J'ai plus de mal à m'imaginer
comment ça va être en bas.
-Voilà.
Ici, on a une association
de tir à l'arc.
Elle va être déménagée
provisoirement.
C'est...
Particulier, en effet,
d'être là.
Je suis la cible.
Je suis la cible
de bon nombre de gens,
je suis l'homme à abattre.
Oui...
-On le dit en rigolant
mais c'est pas drôle.
-Non, c'est pas drôle.
J'y mets tout mon coeur
parce que j'y crois.
Comment refuser cet accueil
à des enfants,
à leurs parents ?
-L'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
est une compétence de l'Etat.
En acceptant de vendre ce bâtiment
à Viltaïs,
Laurent Laroche n'imaginait pas
les conséquences.
-Je me sens menacé,
vous savez.
La personne qu'on vient
de rencontrer,
qui me dit...
Voilà,
"T'as pas honte de me dire bonjour."
Je suis élu,
il n'y a rien qui a changé.
J'ai pas changé.
Je suis comme j'étais.
C'était des gens...
Que je considérais
comme des gens normaux,
aimables,
pour qui j'avais un peu d'estime,
c'est des gens
qui m'avaient rien fait.
Et qui, aujourd'hui, sont dans
une...
Ce monsieur particulièrement est
dans une haine.
-Viltaïs a ouvert 6 CADA
dans la région,
mais l'association n'avait jamais
été confrontée
à une telle hostilité.
-On est démuni,
c'est la première fois.
On en vient à faire des démarches
qu'on avait jamais faites,
c'est-à-dire communiquer
avec les renseignements
territoriaux,
aller déposer des mains courantes
sur les posts diffamatoires
qui sont diffusés
sur tous les réseaux sociaux.
-Il est là-bas.
-En quittant le bâtiment, le voisin
qui avait invectivé le maire
nous interpelle à notre tour.
-Vous avez filmé qui ?
-Le maire.
-Le maire ?
Il y a un maire, ici ?
Ou un collabo ?
-S'il est en colère,
c'est que sa maison est
face au CADA.
Il a bien réfléchi.
Après 20 ans ici,
il a décidé
de quitter le village.
-On veut débarrasser Paris,
soulager les Parisiens,
parce qu'ils en ont peut-être
autant marre que nous.
En ce moment, on vit plus,
on dort plus.
C'est la sécurité,
je suis sûr que la sécurité,
elle y sera pas.
-Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ?
Là, ils ont pas de terrain,
ils ont rien, rien, rien.
Ils disent que ça va être
des familles, j'ai un gros doute.
-Le maire a géré Viltaïs tout seul,
il a rien demandé.
Pourquoi il a pas fait
un référendum ?
-Un projet clivant,
passé sous silence.
C'est ce que reproche une partie
de la population à son maire.
Laurent Laroche, lui,
assume son choix.
-Je n'ai pas commis d'erreur,
de faute. Peut-être,
éventuellement, aurions-nous dû,
peut-être,
je dis bien peut-être,
communiquer plus tôt.
C'est ce qui m'a été reproché.
J'ai appelé une dizaine d'élus
qui ont des CADA en France,
qui ont fait des réunions publiques
et qui l'ont mal vécu,
qui m'ont déconseillé.
Viltaïs n'était pas vraiment
non plus favorable
à une réunion publique
dès le départ.
Du coup, on a avancé comme ça
avec le conseil
et on a fait une réunion
publique après.
On l'a faite en mars,
une fois que le conseil avait pris
la décision de vendre l'usine.
On ne va pas me reprocher ça
pendant un an,
un an et demi.
-C'est pourtant le cas.
Les lettres d'insultes,
de menaces,
s'amoncellent à la mairie.
-C'est un dossier que j'ouvre pas
souvent, il me fait du mal.
-Devant notre caméra,
il accepte de replonger
dans ces courriers.
-"M. le maire,
"chaque jour qui passe
dans ce pays,
"nous subissons les faits divers
les plus atroces par les migrants.
"Nous ne laisserons pas
ce centre ouvrir dans la région
"sans réagir.
Nous ne laisserons pas un collabo
"défigurer le visage de la France
sans rien faire.
"Vous êtes prévenu."
-Ces derniers jours,
les intimidations sont montées
d'un cran.
Trois coups de fil anonymes
à son domicile.
Un homme lui promettait
de lui faire la peau.
Le maire a porté plainte
pour la première fois.
Il vit depuis
sous protection policière.
-Aujourd'hui,
j'ai la boule au ventre.
On n'est pas à l'abri
de rencontrer un fou...
Qui va...
Je sais pas, me tabasser.
C'est inquiétant pour moi,
pour ma famille.
-Ce week-end-là, la tension
ne va pas retomber à Bélâbre.
Une cinquantaine de gendarmes
sont déployés
sur la place du village.
Sous une pluie
battante,
les anti-CADA s'organisent.
C'est Ludivine Fassiaux,
la fille de l'épicier,
qui a pris la tête
de la contestation.
*-On va demander
de garder un rythme assez calme.
Le but, c'est de gagner
un peu de temps
et de montrer qu'on est là.
On a des caméras qui couvrent
cet événement.
-Et le mauvais temps n'a pas
dissuadé
ces Bélabrais
de venir défendre
leur village.
-40 migrants à Bélâbre,
pour la commune de Bélâbre,
c'est trop.
-On veut un Bélâbre
bien tranquille.
Sifflets
-Quel connard, lui !
Je l'aime pas.
-Le cortège
a choisi symboliquement
de passer devant la mairie.
Reclus dans son bureau,
entouré de son équipe municipale,
le maire est tendu.
Depuis ses fenêtres,
il jauge la participation.
-Ils sont pas nombreux,
pas plus que d'habitude.
Même moins, je pense.
Largement moins.
...
Ce qui me fait mal, c'est de voir
des gens de la famille.
Des gens de la famille
pour qui j'ai...
De l'amitié,
des sentiments.
-Laroche, démission !
Laroche, démission !
-Non, je ne démissionnerai pas.
J'irai au bout.
Il y a des gens
du Rassemblement National.
C'est des gens de Bélâbre
qui se laissent influencer
par des discours politiques
nationaux.
-Ce jour-là, ils sont 150
dans les rues du village.
Après 9 mois de contestation,
la mobilisation ne faiblit pas.
*-Ce superbe et chaleureux village
qu'on aime tant
n'est pas équipé, n'est pas prêt
à recevoir un tel projet.
Nous sommes déjà,
nous, Bélâbre, petite commune,
victimes
des difficultés que l'Etat
nous impose : désert médical,
manque de structures...
-Mais c'est surtout un combat
contre l'immigration
qui se joue aussi à Bélâbre.
D'ailleurs, à la tribune,
c'est l'avocat parisien
Pierre Gentillet,
proche du Rassemblement National,
qui est invité
à prendre la parole.
*-C'est une affaire
civilisationnelle.
Ce combat à Bélâbre est
un combat local, bien sûr,
et c'est aussi
un combat national.
Regardez vos villes.
Regardez votre pays.
Le reconnaissez-vous ?
-NON !
-Alors il faut vous battre.
Parce que l'Etat vous a
abandonnés.
L'Etat a abandonné
le peuple français,
comme le maire vous a abandonnés.
Battez-vous.
-Des élus Rassemblement National
des départements
voisins sont venus renforcer
le mouvement.
-ON VA GAGNER, ON VA GAGNER !
-Au niveau national,
quelque chose se passe.
Il faut que nous, élus,
soyons auprès des habitants.
On voit bien que l'Etat
et même les municipalités
laissent les gens à l'abandon,
malgré leurs réclamations,
malgré leur refus
de l'installation de CADA
et cette immigration massive
qui ne cesse.
-Et Ludivine Fassiaux
est bien décidée à faire plier
le maire.
-Callac,
avec la mobilisation de ses locaux
et de l'extérieur,
a réussi à faire plier
la décision.
Si Bélâbre peut être
le petit Callac, pourquoi pas, oui ?
-Callac, ce village breton
dont le maire, harcelé,
menacé de mort,
a fini par abandonner
son projet de CADA.
Loin du bruit
de la manifestation,
à l'autre bout du village,
un petit collectif
s'est réuni.
Eux ne sont pas descendus
dans la rue.
*-A la une, la manifestation
à Bélâbre est terminée.
*-Ils étaient une centaine
pour dire non au centre d'accueil.
150 personnes
selon les organisateurs,
130 selon les gendarmes.
-Sandrine, Céline, Frédéric
et leurs amis
ont monté un collectif
favorable au CADA.
Eux aussi aimeraient bien
faire entendre leur voix.
-On crie moins fort qu'eux.
Je trouve que c'est difficile.
-Dans l'ambiance actuelle,
c'est pas dans le thème
de défendre...
Les demandeurs d'asile,
les réfugiés.
-Les gens qui travaillent
sur Bélâbre,
qui sont artisans,
s'ils annoncent
qu'ils sont pro-CADA,
quel risque ils sont ?
C'est que les gens
fassent plus appel à eux.
-Forcément,
d'un côté ou de l'autre...
on s'est positionnés aussi.
On se fait juger.
Les gens
qui ne disent plus bonjour,
les regards...
Ca, c'est très difficile.
Au début,
j'ai pris le parti de faire
comme si de rien était
en se disant :
"Ca va passer avec le temps."
Je m'en suis fatigué.
Maintenant, je dis bonjour
à ceux qui me sourient
et qui me le disent,
mais après, non.
-C'est compliqué...
Toute cette haine
qu'on a pu recevoir,
qu'on voit encore...
Elle se met à pleurer.
Musique intrigante
-Etre favorable au CADA
à Bélâbre
est délicat pour les habitants,
comme pour le maire.
Mais Laurent Laroche ne désarme pas.
Il croit toujours
à son projet.
Il sait que le parcours
sera long
et bien plus compliqué
que prévu.
-"Monsieur Laroche,
on viendra pas..."
C'est devenu un combat,
parce qu'il a été
très vite mis
sur le champ politique,
mais certains vous diront
qu'accepter
de faire venir un CADA
dans sa commune,
c'est déjà un choix politique.
Au combat politique,
il faut
des réponses politiques.
Le fait d'aller
à Argenton,
participer à la Semaine
de l'intégration,
rencontrer d'autres élus,
ce sont des actes politiques.
-La ville voisine
d'Argenton-sur-Creuse
accueille elle aussi
un CADA.
Elle organise
une Semaine de l'intégration.
La secrétaire générale
de la Préfecture du département
est présente,
et Laurent Laroche
veut en profiter
pour la rencontrer.
*Propos indistincts
-C'est bien que vous soyez venu.
-Oui, tout à fait.
-Et puis comme ça,
ça donne une vision
un petit peu large
de tous les dispositifs.
-Au coeur de la conversation,
les freins à l'intégration.
-On vous laisse pas seuls.
-Mais oui, bien sûr.
-Ce qui est compliqué,
c'est pas de trouver du logement
ou de l'emploi, car on est
à 4 % de taux de chômage.
On voit que les entreprises
sont demandeuses de main d'oeuvre,
donc on peut trouver des parcours
et on peut organiser
l'orientation vers l'emploi.
La question qui se pose,
ce que nous disent souvent les élus,
c'est la mobilité.
-C'est un vrai sujet.
Là, on est sur le point de signer
avec une association départementale,
Familles rurales,
la possibilité de faire
du transport solidaire.
-Mais le plus important
pour le maire de Bélâbre,
c'est de s'assurer
du soutien de l'Etat.
-C'est une politique publique
portée par l'Etat.
Il ne peut pas faire seul.
Il a besoin des élus.
Quand on a des élus
comme monsieur le maire,
très engagés
et qui croient à ce projet,
on se doit, au niveau
des services de l'Etat,
d'être à ses côtés,
de l'accompagner,
voire de mobiliser
des services
aux côtés de l'association
pour faire les choses
dans de bonnes conditions
et que vous soyez soutenu.
Vous ouvrez la voie !
Vous ouvrez la voie, bravo.
Ils rient.
-Voilà.
Je l'ouvre,
mais pas sans dommages.
Il y a
des dégâts collatéraux.
-On vous accompagne.
-Mais je sais.
Musique dynamique
-Au nord du département,
une autre commune
a ouvert la voie
il y a sept ans :
la ville de Buzançais.
4500 habitants,
et un CADA qui accueille
110 demandeurs d'asile.
C'est ici qu'Amina
vit depuis quatre mois.
Elle a fui son pays
suite à des violences familiales.
Pour des raisons de sécurité,
elle souhaite rester anonyme.
-Allez, on va courir 5 minutes
pour faire réchauffer
le corps. OK ?
Allez. Yes.
Allez, on commence.
1, 2, 3, let's go.
-Depuis quelques semaines,
c'est elle qui anime
le cours de danse
de la ville.
-6, 7,
8...
Lorsqu'on a quitté
notre pays,
on a cru qu'on allait vivre ici
en cachette,
mais on pratique notre vie
tranquillement,
on fait ce qu'on veut.
Au début,
ils ont cru qu'on allait rester
comme ça, les bras croisés,
mais lorsqu'ils ont vu
qu'on voulait vivre,
qu'on voulait s'intégrer,
ils ont aimé ça.
-Certains habitants
viennent même assister
à son cours.
Aujourd'hui,
l'intégration se passe bien,
mais à l'époque,
comme à Bélâbre,
le projet n'a pas vraiment été
bien accueilli
par la population.
-Au début, à Buzançais,
on entendait n'importe quoi
sur le marché,
et c'est petit à petit
je crois,
le comportement qu'ils ont eu,
toutes les personnes qui venaient
de droite et de gauche...
Y a pas eu de choses
à leur reprocher.
Ils se sont un peu intégrés,
et donc, ça fait
que c'est comme ça aujourd'hui,
mais c'était pas gagné.
-En sept ans,
190 familles
comme celle d'Amina
ont été hébergées
dans ce centre.
Des familles qui arrivent souvent
des grandes villes, des métropoles.
-Les familles,
la plupart du temps,
quand elles arrivent à Buzançais,
elles ont ce sentiment :
"On est dans une zone
un peu perdue."
La plupart des familles
sont contentes d'être ici,
parce qu'effectivement,
il y a un environnement
qui est paisible,
il y a l'accès à la piscine l'été,
il y a le parc,
il y a des espaces verts,
il y a un peu tout ce qu'il faut.
-Souhaitent-elles pour autant
rester vivre
dans ces villes
de campagne ?
Amina vient d'obtenir l'asile.
Elle a justement rendez-vous
avec sa référente sociale
pour préparer
sa sortie du CADA.
-Tu es quelqu'un
qui s'intègre facilement,
qui au niveau social,
sait beaucoup partager,
donner et recevoir. C'est important,
dans la vie de tous les jours,
et j'ai pas d'inquiétude
par rapport à ça.
-Merci, parce que
je me trouve à l'aise,
je me trouve très bien ici.
-Par rapport
à ton projet professionnel,
là, on va pouvoir faire
une demande d'inscription
à Pôle emploi.
-Est-ce qu'il y a des formations
où je peux faire un projet ?
-Mmh ?
-Quelque chose d'équivalent
à mon travail.
Dans mon domaine, mais...
C'est pas la peine
d'aller dans un autre endroit
pour chercher mon poste.
-En quelques mois,
Amina a trouvé sa place.
Elle envisage
de refaire sa vie juste à côté,
à Châteauroux.
-S'il y avait
des moyens de transport
pour venir tard à Buzançais,
je quitterais jamais Buzançais,
parce que je suis tranquille,
mes enfants sont bien,
il y a plein de sécurité,
personne ne te crée des problèmes,
rien du tout...
-Il faudrait améliorer les choses
en termes de mobilité.
Clairement...
Pour habiter en zone rurale,
il faut son permis,
un moyen de transport...
Les familles qui arrivent ici
ont pas forcément les moyens
de financer un permis.
-Depuis l'ouverture
du CADA en 2016,
trois familles ont choisi
de s'installer à Buzançais,
25 dans le département.
L'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là,
mais elle s'est aussi jouée
sur le terrain de foot
d'un petit village voisin : Argy.
-Soutiens, soutiens !
Encouragements
...
-Ils viennent du Mali,
de la Gambie,
de la Côte d'Ivoire...
Une équipe
vraiment multinationale,
et ça tourne
du feu de Dieu.
-Le club de foot local
allait fermer, faute de joueurs.
Ce sont les réfugiés
de Buzançais
qui ont sauvé l'équipe.
Musique inspirante
-Sinon, c'était fini pour nous.
A six, on peut pas faire une équipe.
Le vendredi, on fermait,
et le samedi, ils sont venus
à l'Assemblée générale
et c'est reparti.
On avait un peu peur
pour la barrière de la langue.
15 joueurs arrivaient d'un coup,
ils auraient pu prendre le pouvoir,
mais ça s'est pas passé comme ça.
Il y a eu tout de suite...
Ouais,
ça s'est très bien passé.
-Nous aussi,
on avait besoin d'un club comme ça,
donc c'était bien pour eux
et bien pour nous.
Ca aide beaucoup
à s'intégrer,
ça t'aide
à sortir des soucis.
-C'est une manière de s'intégrer.
Entre nous, il y a souvent des gens
qui sont assez timides.
Entre nous, ici,
quand on communique,
à travers le sport,
ça facilite déjà le langage.
-En deux ans,
la petite équipe multinationale
a pris du galon
et attiré les regards.
-On a de très bons joueurs.
On est l'équipe à abattre.
Le club était en train de mourir,
au niveau des supporters,
et pour le coup,
c'est cette curiosité,
le fait qu'on soit un peu atypiques
qui a fait venir quelques curieux.
Et la plupart se sont rendu compte
que ça se passait super bien.
-Et depuis quelques mois,
un supporter de marque
assiste aux entraînements.
...
-On va pouvoir acheter
des parkas.
J'ai trouvé des prix...
-Qu'on ait des tenues
un peu ressemblantes.
-Ouais, mais ça va se faire.
C'est l'objectif.
-Oui, parce que...
Vous voyez
comment ils sont habillés ?
-Originaire de Buzançais,
l'ancien patron du PSG
vient là en voisin
et donne un coup de pouce
au club régulièrement.
-C'est une belle histoire.
C'est très agréable d'être là.
J'ai connu
tous les échelons,
de gagner une coupe d'Europe
à me retrouver en 4e division.
Je suis aussi heureux
que dans d'autres histoires...
Il y a plus
de nationalités
dans l'équipe d'Argy
qu'au Real Madrid !
Il rit.
Musique dynamique
...
-A Bélâbre,
quelques semaines se sont écoulées
depuis la dernière manifestation,
mais la tension est loin
d'être retombée.
Le projet a pris
beaucoup de retard.
La signature de la vente
avec Viltaïs est repoussée,
les travaux aussi.
-Imaginons que la signature
ait lieu courant janvier,
vous, les travaux...
Vous avez une idée,
derrière ?
*-Après, il faut qu'on recontacte
toutes les entreprises,
puisqu'on ne leur avait pas donné
de planning ou d'agenda.
-Les anti-CADA
ont investi
le terrain juridique.
Ils ont déposé des recours
au permis de construire.
-On est toujours
dans cette espèce
de pression...
Quand les travaux seront commencés,
quand la vente sera faite,
je pense que ça va retomber,
parce que les gens vont se dire...
-Oui, "c'est fait".
*-La pression permanente,
c'est vrai que c'est éprouvant.
Si monsieur Laroche
nous avait dit "On arrête",
effectivement,
on aurait abandonné ce projet,
mais là,
c'est pas du tout le souhait
de Viltaïs.
-J'aurais eu
maintes occasions d'abandonner.
Je ne pensais pas
que ce serait à ce point-là
et qu'il y aurait
autant de fractures.
-En attendant
l'ouverture du CADA,
Viltaïs doit honorer
son engagement avec l'Etat.
Les 38 demandeurs d'asile
seront provisoirement accueillis
dans une autre ville
du département.
Laurent Laroche, lui,
espère les recevoir
à Bélâbre
à l'automne prochain.
-Je pense qu'un jour,
un certain nombre de Bélabrais,
qui aujourd'hui sont dans la rue,
m'accorderont
que j'ai eu raison.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA